[Music]
finally something good uh an indonesian
student
accidentally becomes a millionaire good
for him accidentally accidentally
because that's great he sold his selfies
as nfts as a joke wow
as a joke and he made a million dollars
what do they look like
wow you don't see him now
we're late literally this is how they
look
just like that i could do that
yeah oh wait was he the kid that
compiled like every single day yeah so
this kid he was gonna make like a time
lapse of his face uh he took a photo
almost every day for i think five years
he earned that man
i think it lasted three days that's a
five-year project that's that's some
utility there you know and then just
literally as a joke he um and this is he
actually tweeted it like i'm gonna sell
these at nft's lol like this was a
literal joke he wasn't hiding the fact
that it was for a joke he posted them
for like three bucks which is like point
zero zero zero zero one ethereum
and then in one day i don't know if it
was the same day but in one day the
price jumped all the way to 12 grand
whoa
per picture
for the ones that we're selling he sold
about 200.
at that time
well i guess they were like well it's
within that five year period it's finite
what does that mean so it's like it's
it's like you could get the collection
from one to five right one year to five
and then it's like it's finite it's like
locked in yeah i guess somebody um i
guess like a celebrity chef caught wind
of it and then he he bought it as a joke
kinda and then i guess after he publicly
did that and tweeted all these people
started jumping on it and then it just
became a crazy thing this was like the
dogecoin of nfts wow yeah that's a good
way just looks funny so we gotta get on
it regardless yeah and now it's legit
and every now and then somebody's gonna
get lucky i'm just waiting for our turn
yeah yeah indonesia i know dude yeah and
what's his name by the way his name is
sultan gustav al-gozali
he's a sultan i might just be my name
oh his mom knew his mom knew he was
going to be a millionaire yeah your name
is sultan
yep he's 22 he was uh he's taking
computer science in school so that's
kind of nice i wonder how you become a
sultan like what the title is the
teacher of that class how he even
figured how to mint it by himself like
with no money
yeah he said he did it just to have a
bit of a laugh and then it blew up and
now uh the collection that was bought is
worth 374 ethereum 1.2 mill wow
that that money is going to go a long
way
what do we got what kind of nfts
what if we all take a [ __ ] and put it
together in the center i think it was
going to buy it she'd have t's yeah and
then we just get to mint it we just have
it there
fudgeable turds yeah we all take a
dookie
non-flushable
and then we just throw like mints at it
y'all can end up tea your greatest hits
you know we're like we mention it right
now what's up i don't even know how it
works i don't know how it works i heard
people can do it do what if you like jk
news the greatest hits you nft them [ __ ]
i think if joe did his own version of
the bored ape yacht club but joe's face
but just different like variations of
joe's face pretty cool yeah yeah yeah
you got to put like not financial advice
next to it when you buy it though you
know you don't know what's gonna happen
with this i wonder if it seems like when
someone does it very openly as a joke if
it's more motivating for people to i
think so because it's like endearing
yeah otherwise you look like you're on
your [ __ ] too hard
check my [ __ ] out
if you look at if you look at the entire
entity space right now right it's like a
whole [ __ ] flex game anyway it's just
big dick club right everybody's like i
got this we got the illest this here's
the road map here's utility check out my
website all these people are gonna blah
blah blah right so when you see like
this indonesia this guy's got every
[ __ ] ingredient and variable to make
it endearing you know what i'm saying
right yeah it's like what's your thing i
took a selfie of myself every day for
five years the [ __ ] like and it's cool
because he was really gonna make a time
lapse for his graduation like he thought
it'd be a cool thing to do see really
just keep everything he says it's just
more endearing graduate to a goddamn
millionaire
you did it
hell yeah in indonesia you get one
million dollars free it's cool because
they asked him what do you what he's
gonna do with that money he said he
wants to open an animation
studio this dude is the best i hope i
get to work with you someday i'll voice
one of your characters let's do it yeah
you're assaulted
let's go
[ __ ] salta vision dude i think if
you're like a quote-unquote celebrity or
have a following like ain't no one want
to buy your [ __ ] because they already
think you got it yeah like even though
you may not have it like i'm not bawling
they're like no you balling something
they're like
you're doing better than me yeah you
don't better
come out of nowhere people just like
it's like liking hazbollah you know what
i mean he's like as well as a little ass
dude he's talking [ __ ] like i don't beat
you about but it's like
everybody likes because you you didn't
go beat me up
nobody wants to say it
he challenged logan paul that's what i'm
saying like
he'll get murdered but it's cute
do you think haas bulla has some nfts
yeah his name is isn't his twitter like
hospital nft now is it what [ __ ] i think
so i think he literally look is let's
let's real talk for once is nft real or
is it beanie baby
it's real wrong
beanie baby feels like [ __ ] are
buying beanie babe like this is gonna be
worth 10 grand did you see that price
guide the price guide from like the
early 2000s for the beanie babies showed
the product the projected 10-year value
of each one and they were like in the
tens of thousands right so it would be
like the 2008 price of this 2018 is like
20 000. but they're nothing now you guys
are idiots i'm gonna scoop up all the
[ __ ] beanie babies and in 10 years
what are you gary vee i'm gonna be
[ __ ] boneless
is nftb we're in the middle of it so we
don't know
i think we're in the middle of it we
don't know this is a bear market
it can be
but the second it's not
is like [ __ ] we missed out
but let's look at this but let's look at
this way all the beanie babies put
together in the world and all their
market value was nowhere near where nfts
are at right now right
impossible inflation though yeah i mean
you gotta account for the inflation
price people thought of that way with
the dot-com stuff too right like or
people just making personal websites and
putting their resumes on there and then
it went
you know so you don't know utility
you're in the middle of it at least the
cool thing is a lot of people so far
around me that i know are buying into
this thing with the notion that i don't
know let's just see right but the beanie
baby fad was like they swore it would be
wrong what about beanie babe where are
we at with beanie baby we're in the
middle of it
i think it's over
well you know what beauty babies did
it like gave birth to the idea that
things could be like that of value
it's a collectible exactly right so so
it's it's just like with the dot-com era
you don't think like dot dot com air is
like almost a blanket statement for many
things but like at the time was it like
netgear yahoo aol
but none of those are around now really
it's like google and all this other [ __ ]
right earth link exactly but at that
time
it was like all of them were hype and
popping so even now with nfts it's kind
of like
this
it could be hot but something else might
be born from it sneakerheads is still
hot like
the stockx like certain sneakers are
still like it's actually hotter than
ever it's actually hotter than him
killing it yeah beanie babies could have
been sneakerhead wait i'll tell you this
though right pokemon was like super
super poppin and then it died out for a
bit and now back yeah and and once
pokemon go hit next revolution and then
it chilled out and now pokemon is doing
the metaverse and i'll guarantee you the
second they're going to still have your
magic the gathering cards i have some
yeah
but you know i ain't gonna i ain't gonna
sell them because you know i'm true fans
look at him of course he plays magic i
play magic digital
like a hearthstone hearthstone yeah
that's that's tied too i hate a lot
until you get to a level where like you
think you're doing good and someone has
some [ __ ] that you and they're like six
from ukraine or something yeah all these
cards and lastly throw some cards out
there and he's just like oh guess what
got all your [ __ ] that [ __ ] hurts so bad
what the [ __ ] you're younger like
baseball or basketball i've had them but
i got basketball cards
you still have them any of them i got a
hell of a basketball
i have an album of like 36 kobe rookies
somewhere at my parents house you got to
go you got to find them you better not
say that on camera bro how much is that
oh yeah you're right it's a lot of money
it's something i can't find it no one
else will be able to find that [ __ ] so
david was over david was over and i had
just one of my binders and we're just
looking and i don't even know what goes
into the price of each so like i went to
like let's say like the jordan section
had like maybe like two or three pages
of those right yeah some of them it's 20
cents some of them's 30 cents and one of
them i typed it in and it was three g's
and i'm like you're gonna get that you
have to get that like like approved and
all that [ __ ] yeah they're just so
random
the time frame that it was printed like
the block at which it was like you know
printed and stuff like that like how
many they were made at what year what
place is it difficult to get a high
rating on the card and it's it's a huge
drastic value difference between like 10
and nine and eight
and the crazy thing is in that era you
got to pay somebody to go approve it you
got to spend a lot of money in order to
see if it's even valuable whereas the
crazy thing with nfts is you already
skipped that middleman prospect it's on
the blockchain that's forever it's
already there all the info is there you
know what i'm saying it's right there
unless you [ __ ] up your wallet and when
and when you're getting and when you're
getting a kobe rookie uh basketball card
or whatever at the time it's not worth
anything because there's always rookies
every year you don't know something
right you don't know who's gonna be so
same with now with the end of tease is
crazy because you're getting stuff and
you don't know if it's gonna pop off
it's all speculation too
that's what happened to me because out
of a thousand of them 999 are going to
not be tight ready collector types y'all
just grew up and kind of like became but
you're just collecting bigger things now
and i made my mistakes i had 57 deadly
shrimp rookies as well
and yeah that's what you would
definitely see he's got a crazy favorite
basketball player your haircut look kind
of like his [ __ ] right now
i don't know
there's a little bit of him in there a
little bit deadly i was never a good
collector i actually back in the day i
won from nestle quick i won like the
whole gobot collection how did you do
that because it was like they were
giving away one or two in the whole
country tonight and i won it i don't
never once
before the transformers and they're all
metal and [ __ ] yeah
the whole collection
my house my dad was like don't open
those i've been like
i got four brothers we're like what
by the end of the month we were shooting
those shits with bb guns and [ __ ] i was
like
what the [ __ ] were we doing
but a collector mine's like oh i'm not i
got the whole collection i'm not going
to open this [ __ ] i'm just leave this
[ __ ] yeah you can sell it one day no uh
back in the day on the radio stations
they would pass out like free concert
tickets
uh geo would get like 10 of them in a
row and then she found out that she were
calling in yeah she was the only one
calling because no one else believed
they would get it yeah so she would get
all these like oh i go to [ __ ]
pennywise concert i go to wherever
concert just constantly just getting all
these concerts because no one was
calling
wow
you just gotta do it she was lucky
no she just no one was calling she was
like she hacked the system maybe her
says maybe her phone line went directly
to the radio station i know someone like
that too
my father lost him you ever listen to
the radio and you hear your friend on it
like yeah like they're like hey i gotta
get a shout out to someone so i'm like
oh [ __ ] people actually do this [ __ ]
that happened to me when me and my
friend were driving in separate cars in
cerritos and i was listening to the same
station as her and she called in and i
heard her on the thing and i turned
around and she was going
oh that's tight yeah and she wants some
concert tickets i guess it does happen
that's dope man
[Music]